in Hollywood films are judged by the
bottom line how much money did they make
how much money did they cost and how
much money did the studio executives get
to pocket but sometimes movies that have
flops at the box office get an
unexpected second life becoming cult
classics as audiences slowly discover
them here's a look at some beloved
movies that totally bombed at the box
office Highlander while today it's
considered one of the best sword &
Sworcery fantasy films of the 80s
Highlander wasn't so well received when
it premiered in 1986 earning a grand
total of twelve point nine million
dollars against a 16 million dollar
production cost once Highlander was
released for the video rental market
though it did much better with viewers
and gained a cult following the fanbase
grew so large that high demand
eventually resulted in the creation of
five sequel films a live-action
television series that ran for six
seasons a series of books and even
comics with a big screen reboot rumored
to be in the works so much for the claim
that there could be only one The
Boondock Saints if it hadn't been for
the now-defunct video rental chain
blockbuster The Boondock Saints never
would have stood a chance showing in
only five theaters in the US the film
meant just four hundred and eleven
thousand dollars worldwide in 1999
despite costing six million dollars to
make then blockbuster stepped in inking
a deal to distribute the film as a
blockbuster exclusive the movie soon
gained a massive cult following bringing
in over fifty million dollars in DVD
blu-ray sales spawning a sequel in 2009
and a new TV series won without stars
Norman Reedus and Sean Patrick Flanery
Scott Pilgrim vs. the world critics
loved Scott Pilgrim vs. the world
calling it funny
heartfelt hilarious vivid and wildly
inventive unfortunately though critics
seem to be the only people who actually
went to the theater to see it as Scott
Pilgrim failed to earn back its
production costs earning less than 48
million dollars worldwide against a
reported 60 million dollar production
budget throw in another twenty five
million dollars spent on advertising
Scott Pilgrim seemed doomed to be a
massive bomb until it sold over 300,000
copies on blu-ray and DVD in its first
week alone Dredd despite a built-in fan
base from the comics and widespread
critical acclaim the 2012 action flick
Dredd earned just 41 million dollars
worldwide which sounds like a lot until
you consider it cost 50
million dollars to make and another 25
million dollars to market part of that
might be lingering bad taste from the
1995 Sylvester Stallone version Judge
Dredd but much of it had to do with bad
timing just a year earlier the cult hit
the raid redemption featured almost the
exact same plot leaving many fans to
consider Dredd a second-rate coffee
judgment whatever the reasons for its
theatrical failure nothing could keep
Dredd down once it hit the home market
where it became an instant success Dredd
sold over 650,000 copies in the first
week it was available on DVD and blu-ray
and by 2017 its total video sale
earnings topped the 20 million dollar
mark leading to rumors of a possible
revival of the franchise The Chronicles
of Riddick
after first appearing in the 2000 film
pitch black vin diesel reprise the role
of Richard B Riddick in the 2004 sci-fi
epic The Chronicles of Riddick with a
budget of 120 million dollars it needed
to be a hit just to break even it wasn't
and it didn't earning just a hundred and
fifteen million dollars worldwide diesel
was even nominated for a Razzie award
for worst actor for his effort
eventually though fans caught on and
slowly turned the Chronicles of Riddick
into a cult hit eventually spawning a
2013 sequel as well as numerous books
action figures and even video games the
Rocky Horror Picture Show it may be the
movie with the longest ever theatrical
run but the Rocky Horror Picture Show
bond during its initial release in 1975
although it was based on a popular stage
musical the film adaptation earned only
twenty one thousand two hundred and
forty five dollars in its opening
weekend the studio yanked the film from
most locations but one exec had a
brilliant idea
why not run it as one of the midnight
shows in the Waverly theater in New York
City literally overnight it became a hit
with the Waverly crowd who just a few
months later turned it into an
interactive experience why shouting
improvised lines at the screen and
singing along the midnight showing soon
spread to other theaters around the
country along with the habit of shouted
audience callbacks eventually dedicated
fans began to form shadow cast
performance troops acting out the film
in costume onstage as the movie plays
out on the big screen behind them within
a year Rocky Horror went from a
box-office bomb to a cult sensation
that's still going strong over 40 years
later
I see you shiver with anticipation
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]